[Music]
well we all know that the easter bunny
does its own thing but for your goodie
basket if you're looking for healthier
options we've got the following
suggestions from mommy blogger
and parenting expert amanda mushroom
wild republic has really great plush and
this is a really cute line
this is their audubon bird collection
and they make
real life bird sounds which i think is
so cute
i don't know if you've heard that little
chicken i just think this chick would be
so
sweet in an easter basket a cute little
thing to snuggle up with
now you've got some other neat things
where you have to find
certain things and images what's this
next one all about
so this is crazy erin's hide inside this
is their putty so
these are from my kiddos that like the
slime and the putty
this has these little tiny this one has
flowers in it but you have to
find images so it's almost like i spy
so you search through the putty and you
find a bumblebee or a ladybug
and it's right on the outside of the tin
so you never have to worry about
finding it but this is just a really
cute thing for the sensory plate
now i gotta say chess is not something
i've tried yet as an adult i know i need
to so what do we have here with the
story time chaps
okay perfect because this one is going
to be for you this i love this this is
story time chess this is how you teach
chess to kiddos
three and up and how they do it is by
telling
silly stories so rather than boring kids
with
this piece does this and this piece does
this it tells a
silly funny story each piece gets a
character and
kids learn how to play chess by
listening to the and interacting with
the story so if you're a parent that
doesn't know how to play chess
that's okay because you can learn right
along with your kids
perfect she's also got guy on the lion a
brand new children's book about a lion
who lives differently than his friends
and we've got brain games ubongo in 3d
which of course is great for traveling
so
you can check out her website at
amandomastro.com to find out where to
place the orders